Harry we come now to chapters 8 through
10 of first Corinthians we've noticed as
we read this letter that there are
places where Paul worries about the same
things where we worry about what's
marriage how does one relate to other
Christians when it comes to suing them
in court his answers may not be our
answers but his problems are our
problems now we come to a really
extended discussion of an issue that
seems not immediately pertinent to us
namely and you're doing I hope you'll
explain to us all what my next sentence
means namely what should Christians do
about eating meat that comes from
temples where the meat has been used in
sacrifices pagan sacrifices alright I
think one of the issues here is that a
lot of meat that was eaten in in a
first-century context was ritually
slaughtered and ritually slaughtered in
a situation that would have involved
pagan deities and so the the question is
really is a boundary question for the
Christian community can they participate
in something that is of religious
significance outside of the community
mm-hmm and there are two opinions within
the within Paul's Corinthian
congregation one based on the kind of
principle that we've seen articulated
before all things there are lawful
everything is okay and another principle
that they had probably learned from Paul
that idols are nothing and so therefore
you don't have to worry about the can
behind them right he's he cites this in
chapter 8 verse 4 as to the eating of
food offered to idols we know that no
Idol in the world really exists and that
indeed there is no god but what these
are principles that they occur in
theater properly learn from Paul a part
of traditional Jewish and early Jewish
Christian catechesis yeah so they draw
the inference from this that it doesn't
matter but not everybody in the
congregation has that same opinion some
people apparently for whatever reason
then we can see what some of the reasons
are in a minute say that no if we eat
meat sacrificed to idols in such a way
as to show our allegiance to those idols
we're not being principled we're not
being faithful to our principles
Christiane's so it is a boundary marker
Paul here shows his pastoral sensitivity
in as clear away as he ever does because
he he argues two positions yeah in
Chapter eight and then in Chapter ten
and there's a little excursus in chapter
nine where he puts himself forward as an
example of the kind of virtue of yoga
that he wants to his Corinthians to
pursue so with chapter eight he sides
with let's say the people who have a
strong conscience on this matter that is
who I'm bothered by eating idle meat and
he says to them I know what the
principles are that that you're
operating with it I agree with with them
and with you I probably taught them to
you yeah but he says look you have a
responsibility to other members of the
community and that's the fundamental
value that he wants everybody to buy
into that people in this community have
a responsibility for one another and
they need need to take one another
seriously even when they disagree and
need to need to bend over backwards to
to make sure that this community holds
together so he says you know if you
offend people who have a different
opinion on this matter you're actually
offending Christ yeah you're doing an
injustice to members of your family you
need to think about this as a family
matter so that's what he says to the
people on the one side who see no
problem with this issue then in Chapter
nine he has this long reflection on
himself as an apostle and on the rights
that he has as an apostle I spoke a
little bit earlier about what it meant
to be an apostle in the first century
were meant for Paul to be an apostle and
he cites some examples of other apostles
is really interesting for thinking about
who's acting as a Christian missionary
and in what way he talks about the
Apostles and the brothers of the Lord in
Chapter 9 verse 3 who have believing why
go with him the first Pope was married I
guess yeah yeah you go with that when
I'm writing the novel on I was Peters
wife and how did that feel when Paul as
we heard in Chapter 7 is celibate he's
for the sake of the kingdom not engaged
in sexual relations at least to this
part of his life but I have a right to
this stuff I also have a right to
support one of the big
shoes for the mergers and second
Corinthians is his relationship with
this congregation and how much money he
does not from their and their insulted
he's not taking money that's right the
congregation I've been looking for
that's we need to up your salary because
you're insulting us by the modesty of
your stipend so yeah so Paul has a right
to support from the congregation he
doesn't take it for whatever reason and
he points that out here he says look I
have rights I don't exercise them why
because what is beneficial what is
beneficial for the upbuilding of the
body of Christ is really at the heart of
what it means for me to be an apostle so
that's the the fundamental value that he
wants to get everybody to be thinking
about uses some other really interesting
a colorful language here about running
the race receiving the prize in chapter
9 verse 24 he was a real athletic fan in
first century and athletes at least in
chapter 10 he gets back to the issue of
meat sacrificed to idols and here he
shows that on one point at least he's in
fundamental agreement with people who
are objecting to this elective more
scrupulous that's right now and so he
starts out with a warning about idolatry
echoing centuries of prophetic warnings
about idolatry and the call to be
faithful to God and God alone so that's
an important part of what he wants to
make sure this community is doing being
faithful to God so he does a Midrash an
interpretation of Scripture which reads
his own experience in the experience of
the Corinthians into the scriptural text
in a way that's quite an Akron estate
quite played out but it's making the
point look the Israelites of the exodus
generation some of them committed
idolatry so the fact that they had
status with God was not a game saving
yeah
you have moral responsibilities and
responsibilities do you have fundamental
commitments everybody's trying to try to
argue and he then locates where those
fundamental commitments and ultimate
values are to be found in the experience
of the Corinthians in chapter 10 verses
14 he he talks about the Christian
ritual meal the Eucharist and he reminds
them
but the cup of blessing that we bless is
not a sharing in the blood of Christ the
bread that we we break is it not a
sharing in the body of Christ this is
their sowing a seed that's going to be
picked up in the next race right who but
it's calling the Corinthians to reflect
on their experience of encounter with
with God in Christ in their ritual meal
yeah and he's saying to do that and to
be faithful to that is incompatible with
a willing and acknowledged participation
in another culture and so his final very
practical advice in chapter 10 verse 23
and following it is again an appeal to
to be aware of be aware of what the
conscience of your brothers and sisters
is telling them and also to be aware of
the situation in which you find yourself
you know and if someone tells you here
have this piece of meat sacrificed to
the god Dionysus you have ever the
medical judgment you have to you have to
indicate that you are a Christian you
have another religion if you just go to
the market and you buy a piece of meat
and it happens to have been sacrificed
that's fine no problem yeah so if it's a
matter of confession in the matter of
taking a stand be prepared to take a
santero so that so that - I hear I'm
hearing two things that I need help if
it's a matter of being called on your
confession as it's not just a matter of
your consciousness because you the odds
are if you buy a piece of meat in the
meat market you know the odds are it was
using temple worship that's not the
thing the thing is somebody calls and
says okay where do you stand on your
confession and at that point you say as
a Christian now that you've called me on
this I can't predict it that's right
okay nice right and the second principle
which doesn't always flow as neatly with
the first is don't do something that
will destroy your fellow Christian right
right don't that will hurt his or her
conscience and I find myself wondering
just now for the first time when we talk
about the communion stuff thinking ahead
not just to 11 but to 12 that if we're
participating in the body of Christ do
we already begin to attend to those
other members of the body or there when
you and I eat communion together and
you're a strong Christian and I'm a weak
Christian do you pay some attention to
because we're part of that same body
we're eating at that table and then that
helps us understand how we share at
other tables - I think I think that's
right and there's a similar kind of
ambiguity because we'll see when fall
uses body language because it's
referring both to the the the
Eucharistic body the sialic body of
Christ on the the communion table and
also they the body politic and those two
are intimately connected and they
they're connected in such a way as to to
imply that you have to take
responsibility for the mom or the body
the body both both bodies yeah both
kinds about it absolutely just one more
quick thing and that is what you alluded
to which is the Midrash on the exodus
story but what do you do about the fact
that Paul imaginatively playfully but
unapologetically marches through the
story and says okay the spiritual rock
from which they drank in the wilderness
was Christ next next passage we would
nobody could pass the Old Testament
interpretation at Yale Divinity School
announcing that as they read this story
the rock was Christ yeah what's he doing
well in this postmodern age they make
good yeah they way they wouldn't pass
your course there are some of our
colleagues they could float right
through indeed I think what's going on
here is is a reflection of Paul and his
dialogue with Apollo's remember yeah a
guy coming from Alexandria who has some
sense probably the the sense that we
have on the Gospel of John that Christ
is somehow the wisdom of God Carnot and
that wisdom of God was was there and the
experience of the people of the Old
Testament and so Paul can point to
particular aspects of the the experience
of the life of Israel and say yeah
Christ that's wisdom of God or was
somehow there in that moment so it's
playful but there's a little but is a
foundation too wildly liberal now very
interesting thank you